a models phoenix rising the ubisoft game
formerly known as gods and monsters
has a sprawling bright world for you to
explore
fight within and solve puzzles around
despite its surface differences
there's more than a few aspects of the
game that you may find awfully similar
to the legend of zelda breath of the
wild
here are eight of them a bright open
game world
the first thing you'll notice in
immortals is its bright and colorful
world
set in ancient greece immortals has a
giant map to explore
not unlike the kingdom of hyrule there
are massive mountains and dark caves
rolling hills with enemies to take on
and even horses to tame
in our three-hour session with immortals
we only saw one chunk of the map
but we're told there's plenty of diverse
locations to be discovered
from mountainous peaks down to the
cavernous depths of the underworld
game director scott phillips said the
game has been designed with intriguing
landmarks in mind
that'll catch your eye from a distance
and offer up some kind of interesting
experience when you arrive
player driven freedom of exploration
much like breath of the wild your main
objective in immortals phoenix rising is
clear from the outset but where you go
from there is pretty much
up to you your ultimate goal is to save
four gods of ancient greece who've been
defeated at the hands of the big bad
typhon
they're spread out across different
locations around the map but how and
when you choose to proceed is largely up
to the player
and exploration is encouraged voices in
your head
where breath of the wild was punctuated
by the ethereal divine voice of zelda
immortals phoenix rising also pops godly
voices into your head
throughout your journey you'll hear the
voices of zeus and prometheus narrating
your more significant moments
providing commentary and contextualizing
your actions within the larger hero
journey
so this whole story you're telling me
about how you think this mortal named
phoenix has a chance to free all the
gods from typhon's grip
and then destroy him good luck
speaking of which link and phoenix have
a few things in common too
okay so link isn't a demigod with wings
but both protagonists share similar
designs as bright light characters
and each is prophesized to defeat the
evil threatening and corrupting the game
world
stamina and traversal just getting
around the game world will give you
serious breath of the wild vibes
you have a stamina meter that gradually
decreases as you run
or if you're galloping on your horse it
appears you can also climb just about
anything in the game world
but your stamina will drop as you do so
you'll want to be wary of that or risk a
painful landing
luckily and also in the vein of breath
of the wild you can deploy your
brilliant blue demigod wings to glide
down from heights
and there's the option to speed up as
you do there are also potions you can
down halfway up a tricky climb that will
top up your stamina to get you the rest
of the way
that brings us to potion crafting you
can equip
four potions at any one time which do
things like up your stamina and health
the world is filled with resources you
can pick up and munch on for a minor
health increase
but what you'll really want to do is hit
up one of the game's cauldron locations
where you can craft potions using
various combinations of items
just like in breath of the wild puzzles
and shrines
of vaults in addition to being an action
adventure game immortals takes another
page out of breath of the wild's
playbook with its numerous puzzles and
shrines
or vaults as they're known in mortals
players can enter the vaults to take
part in trials of not only strength and
dexterity but also
wits these vaults take place in a
different dimension that is not bound by
the normal rules of the world
which opens up unique possibilities for
puzzles outside of the vaults you can
find puzzle scenarios in the game world
and you can earn special items for
completing them one massive similarity
here
is a mortal's version of breath of the
wild's magnet ability
in immortals you have a number of divine
weapons and abilities
one of which is heracles strength this
allows phoenix to move heavy objects and
magically levitate orbs to solve certain
puzzles in the open world
even the animation where phoenix runs
with hoisted objects above her head
using this ability
is sure to give you serious zelda vibes
unlocking the map
much like towers in breath of the wild
in immortals you'll be on the lookout
for massive statues that you can ascend
to remove the fog from an area of the
map
you'll then need to use the farsight
mechanic to spot locations and mark
icons or simply travel to a point of
interest and then it'll pop up on your
map
game director scott phillips also told
us that there are some soft lock
limitations on traversal
as there are certain skills you might
need to access new areas
or places you can't reach with the
stamina you have fast-paced
flashy combat another major element of
immortals that may give you zelda vibes
is
its combat you're constantly fighting
for survival in the harsh world that's
overrun with monsters of all types
just like in hyrule immortals has a deep
combat system that lets you use multiple
different skills and abilities to lay
waste to your foes
in our playthrough we found that using
your hephaestus hammer ability was
almost always the most effective
approach
for more close quarters combat immortals
offers up light and heavy attacks as
well as a parrying system
players can of course also dodge and
getting the timing just right will slow
down time to help plan your next attack
similar to breath of the wild enemies
are designed as colorful fantastical
monsters
and the greek mythology setting provides
some fun encounters with legendary
creatures as in breath of the wild your
bow is a valuable asset
in one memorable sequence we shot a
cyclops in the eye with an arrow from a
long distance using a special ability
called apollo's arrow
that lets you control the arrow and
guide it in slow motion
let me know what you think of the game
so far in that comment box and stay
tuned for all our coverage on this one
and everything else we saw at the latest
ubisoft forward
you